[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right a lot of basketball moves over
the weekend i thought the lakers did
really really well and i thought let's
bring in chris mannix to kind of
summarize everything that happened
sports illustrated nba senior writer
busy weekend here mannix uh the most
surprising
positive move of the weekend was what
uh positive i'm not
sure i mean i i thought you said the
lakers did well i agree with that
um i think marc gasol is a very useful
pickup for them at the end of all this
and
you know the changes they make to the
backcourt wesley matthews
among others are i think are going to
work out for that team
i really like what the bucks did um you
know i know they wanted
bogdanovic that was their top choice in
that signing trade i thought they
rebounded pretty well
from that you know by you know getting a
guy like bryn forbes and
a handful of others to bobby portis to
fortify that bench
uh bringing back pat conadan who i think
is going to play a big role for that
team and
look it they still have drew holiday who
addressed a lot of issues for them
uh there so look it wasn't anything
seismic
i think that that that tipped the
balance of power in a significant way
but
uh you know the top teams i thought did
well in
sort of refortifying their positions
well let me go back to the lakers
because i don't know if they're done yet
i saw where mark stein
said that the lakers and clippers trying
to sign uh markief morris
you know this is i don't know if it's
you know these players
are more apt to want to play with lebron
the point guard lebron
and be a part of a championship team you
know i i think
montrez harrell you know walking from
one side of the
the the staples center to the other side
i mean
that's pretty seismic move it feels like
there that you want to try to cash in
and win a championship it feels like
do you get that feeling that these
players all you know all in on
getting a chance play with lebron and
plan a chance to win a title
well i mean yes and no um
you know with market morris it's just a
weird situation like he and his brother
are as inseparable as you possibly can
be when you play for different teams and
he would really like to play alongside
his brother if the clippers can make
that work so
that's that's one aspect of it the the
market for harold
wasn't great and that surprised me a
little bit because
he's coming off uh you know the year
he's coming off but it wasn't
uh exceptionally robust market for how
which is why i think he
you know look it's a two-year deal but
it's really a one-year deal with the
option so
he could punt to free agency in 2021 and
see
you know as the there's gonna be more
teams with with free agent cash
available as teams load up for that
summer so
maybe you can cash in that year and look
with harold
like he's a really good player don't get
me wrong but i'm not exactly sure
about the fit with anthony davis because
we know davis likes to play alongside
you know traditional big men right like
he doesn't want to be a five
um he's accepted spurts at the end of
games and in the playoffs he wants to
save his body against that wear and tear
i mean harold can play five but he's not
your traditional type of five that's why
i think the gasol signing
was badly needed in the aftermath of of
losing dwight howard i mean gasol
not what he used to be but i think he'll
be an incredible weapon
top of the key passing the ball shooting
threes and just basketball iq i think
he's uh
going to be a real threat for for that
team so harold's a good player
but i was harold plus gasol made me
think the lakers had a good day
did the hornets have a good weekend
i don't know what the hornets are doing
or what their
their thought process is like
gordon hayward gordon hayward won the
offseason
and mark bartlestina's agent they won
the offseason i couldn't have imagined
after opting out of a four year or a 34
and a half million dollar
contract for next season in boston that
there would be 120 million
dollars on the table from for him there
were teams interested i mean tom
thibodeau
really pushed gordon hayward to new york
indiana tried to construct a signing
trade
but the idea that the hornets would be
there with a buck 20
is is mind-blowing this is the same
hornet's team that kind of
shrugged its shoulders at kemba walker
at least didn't didn't go all out to try
to resign kemba walker
just a year ago this is a hornet's team
that tied itself to nick batum a few
years back
in what was an awful contract that they
are now stretching
so they can sign gordon hayward so
gordon hayward dan's gonna make 30
million
dollars a year himself but because of
the nick platoon stretch if that's how
it plays out which i think it will
gordon's going to be costing like 39
million dollars a year
that that is truly bonkers for a team
that isn't going anywhere
like they're like what are they going to
do go from like with gordon haber go
from 12th
in the western in eastern conference to
10 like i i don't i don't understand
michael jordan mitch cupchak the
thinking there they got lamela ball
he brings some star power you want to
build around him gordon's 30.
like are you just bringing him in to
give lamelo someone to pass to
for a couple of years has you missed the
playoffs i i just i thought nick batum's
contract as an expiring
would have been much more valuable in
some kind of trade scenario where teams
are trying to cut
cut costs for next summer if giannis is
available then just waving him
and making gordon effectively a 40
million dollar for your player
does everybody have to get a max you
know like donovan mitchell
and jason tatum like it's it's five 195
and that's it like there's no other
option where you go
hey maybe you'd like to give you a five
for 175.
why is it it feels like this is like nfl
quarterback contracts where
next guy up or everybody's getting the
max amount
at quarterbacking position and then
these nfl max deals
yeah i mean not on rookie contracts
like if a player is at an all-star level
they become a max guy and part of that
is the cops that are out there right
like
the second free agency open sacramento
gave the aaron fox the max
so if you're todd of a mitchell you're
not considering not the max anyway and
utah wasn't considering it either
but the fact that the aaron fox is a max
guy you are a max guy if you're jason
tatum if those guys are max guys
you're a max guy they just like you you
can't
because these have been handed out and i
agree they get handed out almost
reflexively
at this point uh because they're handed
out so frequently
there's almost no choice for teams to do
i mean players
you know if i was a team maybe i'd play
a little bit of hardball
because no player in the history of
these contracts ever turn one down
because
if they take let's say the qualifying
offer that's not money they can ever get
back
right like if you're a player that signs
a shorter term deal
you could always recoup money on the
back end but if you sign a qualifying
offer
that means for like a jason tatum i'm
just making this number up but it's like
10 million dollars
in that first year you can't make up
that money so you want the 20 million
in that first year of the extension so
they'll they're always going to take it
at least be inclined to take it
maybe teams should play some hard ball
but i have no i have no belief dan
that's ever going to happen any updates
on james harden
no he's not going anywhere anytime soon
i i i expect james harden
to be in training camp with the rockets
which isn't saying much since that opens
like tomorrow or
you know right around the corner um my
sense from talking to people in houston
and talking to people that have
inquired is that this is going to be a
protracted process
and i think i said this to you last time
i was on
and it remains true the westbrook domino
kind of has to fall first
you know they have to find a home for
westbrook i don't know
where that is the washington deal kind
of raised an eyebrow because i'm not
sure what you do with john wall either
in that situation seems like you know
exchanging one distressed asset for
another
but i i don't expect a hardened deal to
happen
until westbrook is there's an outcome
there
and look you do want to get teams into a
bidding war so maybe that takes
until mid-season to get these teams to
realize
you know let's say yama signs the
extension next week
like you you don't want to you know make
a deal for harden when other teams might
who are preparing for giannis might be
available team like miami
or somebody else that might throw a real
offer at you so i i don't expect
anything to happen
any time soon with james harden wait i
thought hardin wanted to play with
westbrook
like when did like he's okay now not
playing with westbrook right
well he's gonna go down the list of
ex-teammates right westbrook and now
durant
and chris paul first of all reuniting
with the clippers i
i don't think that i don't think there's
a any friction with russ and james i
just think look there
like many people have done most thought
they were a tough match
like you know you you put two guys
together
that are used to being alphas that have
two of the highest usage rates
in nba history and it's not easy to come
together now to russ's credit i think
russ changed
you know during the year i think he
evolved as a player to
to make things more accommodating to
playing with james but it just
it just didn't feel like a long-term fit
when they acquired him
and it still doesn't feel like a
long-term fit now good to talk to you as
always chris thank you buddy
ricky rubio on the move again dan yeah
back to minnesota
i already have my minnesota rubio jersey
so i don't need a new one now
i'm good chris manning sports
illustrated nba senior writer